[Music]
thank
you I'm Brian Green and in tonight's
program we're going to explore an idea
really a a dream that Albert Einstein
perhaps
articulated in the most scientific way
in the early years or mid years of the
20th century which was this this goal
that through the decades has been
refined and that goal is to have what he
called a unified theory a theory that
would describe all forces and all matter
from one consistent coherent perspective
metaphorically maybe even a single
Master equation that would
describe everything and and a little bit
more concretely in Einstein's day he
imagined putting together his
understanding of gravity which is the
general theory of relativity which we
will briefly discuss with our
participants in just a moment putting
together our understanding of gravity
with our understanding of the
electromagnetic force and in the decades
that followed that dream grew to not
only include gravity and
electromagnetism but also the nuclear
forces the strong nuclear force the weak
nuclear force and the goal was to put
all of that together with quantum
physics into a single coherent package
now Einstein did not achieve this goal
of finding the unified theory we have
not yet achieved it ourselves but many
of us feel that we are enroot toward
that unified theory and what we'll do
here tonight is discuss how one
particular approach called String Theory
which emerged really as far back as the
late 1960s as we'll discuss really began
to mature in the 1980s and developments
have continued on ever since we'll
describe what that is and try to give a
feel for where we are in this search for
the unified theory and wonderfully
tonight we have a powerful group of
theorists whose work is responsible for
many of the deep insights that we have
into string theory and physics and
Mathematics more generally and they will
be our guides to this world of string
theory and unification so let's begin
bringing in our first guest Andrew
strominger who is the Gill e York
professor of physics at Harvard
University a founding member of the
black Hall initiative in 2017 he was
awarded the Breakthrough Prize in
physics for transformative advances in
Quantum field Theory string theory and
Quant quum gravity hi Andy thank
you our next guest is Edward Whitten who
is Charles shimone professor in the
school of Natural Sciences at The
Institute for advanced study he's made
important contributions to both
mathematics and physics and is the only
physicist to have won mathematics
highest award the fields
medal thank
you
and finally we have David Gross who is
the Chan's chair professor of
theoretical physics and the former
director of the cavy Institute for
theoretical physics at the University of
California Santa Barbara in 2004 gross
shared the Nobel Prize in physics for
the discovery of asymptotic freedom and
the theory of the strong
interaction all right jump jumping right
in I think many of us are familiar with
this quote that's often attributed to
Lord Kelvin although it's unclear
whether Lord Kelvin actually ever said
it but the sentiment is certainly an
interesting one to take a look at I'll
read it from here so I can see it the
great principles have already been
discovered in physics will be henceforth
limited to finding truths in the sixth
place of
decimals now whether or not this was
actually said in those words I think
there was a feeling at the end of the
19th century that a lot of things have
been figured out and maybe what was left
were details people were wrong but but
what led Andy do you think people have
at least a certain kind of confidence
that maybe physics was reaching an
end um I you you hear that semi-
periodically that physics has reached an
end we've reached the end of of of what
we can understand and uh that happens
and uh but then somebody comes up with
usually a completely new and
unexpected uh idea about how to go
forward and something that might have
seemed like a small little corner indeed
I think when Lord Kelvin maybe I have
the dates wrong but there was already
the mikkelson morly experiment and that
was like we just have to explain that
little experiment and out of that little
experiment grew all of
Relativity and so we never
know uh if we make a program about how
physics should
proceed on into the future we will
surely fail because the real route is
somewhere we we can't expect yeah and
that keeps happening and happening now I
was going to move on but I can't help
but jump to David Gross who is shaking
his head throughout your entire answer
no Andy's answer is fine I just don't
understand Lord Kelvin ah I mean at that
time there was no theory of matter in
any form we didn't know how stars shine
I can't believe he made the statement
since I have enormous respect for maybe
he didn't right probably that's probably
correct but people love that because it
puts you know these elitist scientists
to shame how wrong they were
uh well regardless of whether Kelvin
said something like that or not it is
true that lots of things that ultimately
became part of physics weren't even part
of what physicists even imagined being
able to explain in those days like why
does copper conduct electricity that was
not regarded as part of physics in the
19th century right so even our goalposts
change over time advances allow us to
push the goal post further down now Andy
mentioned relativity and of course one
of the big developments after that
statement whether it was actually said
or not but certainly after Lord Kelvin
had made his major contributions was the
discovery of special relativity and then
the general theory of relativity I want
to jump right to general relativity
Edward we had a theory of gravity that
Newton gave us it did a pretty darn good
job there were certain things that it
seemed to leave out like how does
gravity actually exert influence from
place to place Einstein comes along and
gives us a new paradigm in terms of like
warps and curves and SpaceTime can you
just give us a feel for this new way of
thinking about
gravity uh a very simple
assignment so one thing so first of all
why did Einstein reject Newton's Theory
it was not he had already discovered
special relativity which taught us
that first of all familiar ideas break
down when velocities are close to the
speed of light and that the speed of
light is really a fundamental limit that
you can't go beyond in Newton's Theory
there was instantaneous action at a
distance that had bothered Newton and
many of his contemporaries
philosophically but there didn't seem
any contradiction with anything they
knew to Einstein there was and just very
quickly so you mean obvious you know if
you change the position of the sun the
Earth will immediately feel that change
right yeah that was true in Newton's
Theory it did bother people but it
didn't contradict anything they knew to
Einstein had contradicted what he knew
when he had discovered special relative
theal liit and teally Newton's didn't
the right symmetry of special relativity
it has G what later was called Galilean
symmetry which actually was roughly
formulated by Galileo not quite in a
modern sense it did not have Lenin
variance which is the name we use for
the theory of the symmetry of Einstein's
theory so he knew that Newton say he had
to be wrong and he had to do something
but what I've always found surprising
there is actually a Simple Theory that
is consistent with special relativity
and with experiments of the day the
Nordstrom Theory and I've always been
amazed that Einstein didn't invent that
it's so much simpler than General
artivity I I'm sure he considered it but
there were something else that Newton
had implicitly but didn't make a big
point of was the equivalence principle
the fact that the source of gravity
gravitation what we call gravitational
mass and the inertial mass that governs
motion of particles were proportional
identical for which is why all bodies
fall with the same
acceleration uh no matter what they're
made out of which supposedly galile had
had observed and formulated Newton just
took that as a fact Einstein thought
that was incredibly deep had to be a
reason for it and he used that to
motivate his theory but I think the real
motivational Force aside from the
conflicts with special relativity or the
fact that Einstein was always governed
by the idea that there's no privileged
Observer not just inertial observers
moving with constant velocity same
physics on a train moving at constant
velocity as in this room where you know
we're all at rest right with respect to
what but but anyway he also wanted to
generalize the notion to accelerated
observers as well and that led
together with the equivalence principle
to
geometrize so let's even just show the
geometry just so people get a feel for
it many of you have seen Graphics like
this before but you know basically
Einstein says a body like the sun warps
the SpaceTime region around it and then
other objects say here the planets move
in these interesting trajectories
because they're kind of rolling along
the warps and Curves in the SpaceTime
environment so it's a very beautiful way
of incorporating the equivalence
principle a very beautiful way of
resolving the issue that Edward raised
because if you were to shake the sun it
would send a ripple in the fabric of
space that would need to travel from the
Sun to the Earth it wouldn't be
instantaneous indeed it would travel at
the speed of light and again just to
show that Einstein wasn't just thinking
in pictures we can bring up Einstein's
equations as well just to know that
there's deep mathematics that captures
all of that geometry great so this is
one development that happened after it
was perhaps said that the only new
things to be discovered were in the
sixth place of decimals the next thing
of course that was discovered or
although I'm talking at temporally right
now but quantum mechanics was also a big
one so an equally challenging assignment
Andy can just give us a sense of what
quantum mechanics is and why were we led
to it from our observations of the world
is this harder or easier than the
Su um I think I think it's actually a
little harder okay so um you might think
that you could measure uh perfectly
where I'm sitting here and you might
also be able to say I'm
completely perfectly
still but according to Quantum Mechanics
that's a logical
impossibility um if my position is known
exactly I've got to be wobbling around
so there's
some uh there's some
uncertainty in how well you can
describe the both the position and the
motion of of any object and what's so
unusual about this
is it's some Maybe maybe it's the first
thing that happened in physics that was
really really
counterintuitive um the nature of
physical objects just isn't what we
think it is we think that's described by
their position and their motion but it's
actually those are only approximate
Concepts that come out of the schinger
wave function there's a there is
something that is completely well
described but it's indirectly related to
the the the things that we in it are
properly described and I think with
quantum
mechanics we entered a realm where our
intuition was as not a good as it guide
as it had been during the previous
centuries in fact we were forced as you
say to revise our very language that we
use to describe reality before quantum
mechanics as you're saying it was where
things are and how they're moving that's
the data of reality yeah quantum
mechanics comes along and says Whoa you
can't even specify those features at the
same time and indeed it transitions
instead to a probabilistic language in
which the best you can do is talk about
the likelihood of something being at one
place or another now Edward how would
you grade general relativity and quantum
mechanics on their own I
mean well they're each stupendously
successful and they terms yeah I mean
amazingly so and yet when we are forced
to do calculations that put general
relativity and quantum mechanics into
Union I mean what what happens well we
get a
mess but before we get to that mess we
perhaps should mention that it's all
difficult just to combine Quant
mechanics with special relativity but
that was done successfully and led to
what's really our most powerful theory
in the microscopic World Quantum field
Theory yeah also our most difficult
Theory I believe so that part of
Relativity does work with quantum
mechanics and is amazingly powerful
and is powerful in a way that greatly
accelerated the progress of physics in
the 20th century but if we try to
include gravity yes we get a mess and by
mess often we say the calculations all
yield sort of a nonsensical answer they
nonsensical answers at the
beginning Quantum field theory was well
understood and people did not know
whether to take this seriously but when
the other problems many of the other
problems were solved and this one
remains it came to stand out and the way
the nonsense or the results that make no
sense often crop up as you do a
calculation and sort of regardless of
what the input is you get infinity as
the output and infinity in this context
doesn't mean big it just means we don't
know what we're doing somehow when you
put the laws of the big general
relativity laws of the small quantum
mechanics together it doesn't quite
work C can you give us a feel for
why or do if you want to go to I think I
just interrupted Your Chain of Thought
so feel free to go wherever you want no
it's not just in it's the lack of
predictability yeah so in treating
quantum gravity by using the framework
of quantum field Theory uh we can do we
could do pretty well if we had
experimental evidence to try to predict
but we'd have to roduce new parameters
so with our modern understanding of the
theory of quantum fields we we have ways
of temporarily dealing with infinity of
course ultimately we would like to be
completely
predictive and that is in a sense the
problem we could at any energy scale and
so far will have not been able to
achieve energies to test the quantum
effects of gravity we could construct a
framework but at the price of
introducing new
parameters unlike but the theories that
Edward discussed that where Quantum
field theor has given us a very complete
and the finite number of parameters we
can predict thousands of experiments
with great Precision in quantum gravity
ultimately
we would appear to have to introduce an
infinite number parameters which means
in a sense we can't ever predict predict
anything yeah everything yeah right and
scientists such as Einstein and now more
and more of us with the successes of our
theory of Elementary particles
say have the dream of predicting
everything right or at least a finite
number with a finite number of
parameters yeah that Quantum you know
the quantum field Theory approaches to
quantum gravity do not seem to yield
they have been tried now
for 70
years which takes us to an approach
which might be able to do well before we
get there though I want to just spend a
moment giving the audience a sense of
the achievements that you are referring
to in the more conventional approach
that Edward mentioned of quantum field
Theory uh Andy if you don't mind I'll
throw it to you again Quantum field
Theory the operative word is field you
just give us a feel for What a field is
and sort of how part articles are
related to them well Quantum field
Theory at first in instance as Edward
alluded to a few minutes ago it's a
theory which consistently puts together
quantum mechanics with Einstein's dictum
that thou shalt not go faster than the
speed of light namely special
relativity and that was really quite an
achievement putting that putting that
together it really occupied a huge
fraction of the 20th century I'd say
that uh the culmination of the
conceptual and detailed under
understanding of of that as applied to
the physical world was what David was
awarded the Nobel Prize for in the late
in in the well the work done in the in
the early '70s and and we just recently
lost a a great uh quantum field theorist
uh Tom kosa who who calculated the
anomalous Magnetic Moment of the
electron to 16 decimal places by the way
I was two offices down from his and I
show he showed me it was an incredible
amount of calculation his he started on
it in in pre-World War II Japan yeah and
he was still working on it and and many
other many other people uh worked on it
and this is the most
accurate uh agreement between Theory and
experiment in the history of human
thought it is just a remarkable
achievement of of of the human mind and
all the more mysterious it is that when
we go on to
Einstein's next gift to US general
relativity that
we're you know we're still up in the air
so so a field then is a it's a kind of
substance
that that fills space I kind of like to
think of it almost like as Steam as
filling space and The Field's value is
dynamical it can undulate up it can
undulate down if we use quantum
mechanics to describe the field we find
that on microscopic scales the field is
actually composed of little particles so
the particles in some sense are the
quantum mechanical ingredients that make
up this idea of a field you know David
your work of course was instrumental in
establishing the culmination of this
program the so-called standard model of
particle physics and so this is you know
a Monumental achievement but you try to
put gravity in problems arise and as
David was alluding to just a moment ago
that takes us to this new approach
called String Theory as an attempt to
amarate these problems so let's move on
then to that discussion and and before
we do I just want to ask one question
that somewhat surprised me a while ago
there was an article in the New Yorker
where Freeman Dyson who you know of
course was your colleague at The
Institute for Anan study was saying that
we don't need to put general relativity
and quantum mechanics together just like
use general relativity for where it
works Quantum Mechanics for where where
it works and you don't need to put them
together I mean I have my own arguments
I think we all do for why that is but
can you just give a sense Edward why is
it important for them to play well
together well gravity is important for
stars but stars are ultimately made out
of atoms so it doesn't make much sense
to use quantum mechanics for individual
atoms and turn around and use a
completely different and inconsistent
theory for the whole star yeah I mean
David do you want to add some I think
it's actually inconsistent you can if
you just
treat um Gravity by classical physics
you'll run into contradictions with
because after all objects that as edbert
said that behave Quantum mechanically
it's we use quantum mechanical theories
to to understand how Stars Burn also
have gravitational effects and it simply
is logically
inconsistent appears to me I not sure
there's a rigorous mathematical proof
but it's kind of for a physicist it's
obvious yeah and Andy I mean what are
some concrete Realms I mean things that
we actually study in which you
absolutely have to put them both
together to make progress well so of
course one thing would be if you wanted
to compute quantum mechanical
corrections to the Earth's orbit around
the sun it would be insanely small yeah
we'll never measure them or if you
wanted to compute the gravitational
corrections to the energy levels of the
hydrogen atom that would also be
insanely small on the other hand and
there's one place where they're huge and
where we need both quantum mechanics in
gravity and that's in black holes and
now we're seeing black holes all the
time up in the sky and we need to
understand their properties and we need
both it's clear that we to fully
understand to understand the black hole
the way we understand the hydrogen atom
in in in detail we will need in full
force both quantum mechanics and general
relativity so that's certainly one
domain the other domain that we often
use of course is you know cosmology Big
Bang if you sort of run the cosmic
expansion as we see here back in time
everything comes on top of each other
huge amount of mass small space you need
both general relativity and quantum
mechanics so I think it's pretty clear
that that that this is a real issue that
we have to put them together and so
String Theory but but was pointing you
know to an important phenomena an
unfortunate phenomena which is that it's
so hard it's impossible so far to
directly observe or measure the quantum
effects of gravity it seems hard to
imagine how to do that so in the near
future for sure and that is yeah so uh
partly it was there have been other
people I'm not sure Dyson was B based
argument on that that for a variety of
practical reasons based on what we know
it seems almost impossible to test for
the quantum effect yeah and we'll we'll
find that very same issue with string
theory as an example but we should say
out front any theory that tries to put
gravity and quantum mechanics together
will face the same challs that you just
articulated and that's a fact it's not a
shortcoming of our attempt to do so or
of theoretical physics it's a fact of
nature yeah we're kind of
small and
large at the same time and that's makes
life difficult so we're small on Cosmic
scales we're large on Quantum scales and
here we are stuck in the middle uh so so
so Edward can you give the you know you
know 1980s 81
8283 uh you know Michael Green John
Schwarz are sort of thinking about this
new idea called String Theory were you
were you working on it you were
obviously aware of what they were doing
but where were you I was sort of in the
neighborhood but not seriously working
on it yeah and then so 1984 they have a
breakthrough and they give rise to this
very basic idea I mean how would you
articulate Allah say 1984 the basic idea
of string theory well the basic idea of
string theory at least in its simplest
terms is that an elementary particle is
not a point
particle as in sort of conventional
physics but a little Loop of string but
when I say that you have to remember on
both sides that there's quantum
mechanics so the point particle is fuzzy
because of this Quantum uncertainty that
Andy told us about likewise for the
string so you have to imagine a string
that abays Quantum field Theory laws
that will be hard perhaps to imagine but
to to explain why it leads to
unification the basic reason is that
like a piano string or a violin string
this kind of string can vibrate in many
different ways
in the case of the piano string the
beauty of music comes from the interplay
of the different harmonics a tuning fork
produces a pure tone but it sounds harsh
to the human ear in the case of the
string it vibrates in many different
ways and if string the is correct the
different modes of vibration correspond
to the different Elementary particles so
unification is achieved because the
different particles are different forms
of vibration of one basic string so say
in the standard model of particle
physics that you know rightly laed as
our
understanding of the elementary
ingredients there is a separate field
for the electron a separate field for
the electron neutrino for the quarks and
so up down St change and so forth so in
in string
theory that proliferation of ingredients
is Unified from the get-go it's unified
and you can't add extra ingredients even
if you want to you're stuck with what
you get and actually you should be
asking David because David was involved
in the early period when the theory was
developing yeah but yeah the remarkable
thing that so this attempt you know
Stringer is actually older than 84 it
had been around for a while 68 really uh
but at that point in time it seemed
possible perhaps to construct this
unified theory of all the forces that we
had a pretty good understanding of
already and and had enumerated you
showed the I think the list of particles
and
forces and when these ideas came along
due to you know the work that actually
all three of us were involved in it
suddenly appeared possible to unite them
and nothing was
missing and not only nothing was missing
in his attempts to
unify but there was nothing that stuck
out that couldn't be included you know
which is still appears to me to be an
absolute Miracle or better yet a clue
that something is right in these ideas
although you know originally we were all
extraordinarily excited this was a
framework in which one
could produce as vibrations of a fun one
fundamental object all the stuff we saw
and furthermore there was nothing else
we saw that didn't fit into this
framework so okay here obviously we're
on the clue to find the unique theory
that Einstein was looking for and I
can't help but just that right so we'll
get to that I just can't help jumping in
I think I've noted to to you David I
think but I was a student at Oxford as a
graduate student in
1985 and you came and gave a talk at the
Rutherford lab and you described some
work that you said your very good
student was undertaking Edward Whitten
and it was you know there the most
amazing thing to be a student at the
time as these new ideas were bubbling up
and and one of the most exciting IDE
ideas is that
gravity is intrinsically within this
idea of vibrating strings I mean it just
comes out so naturally Andy can just
describe like how does gravity fit into
the string picture well the string is
everything and as as uh as as Edward
started to describe just as when a
guitar string vibrates
differently
um it sounds differently when a string
moves in different way it looks
differently yeah now it turned out to be
some very complicated mathematics to
understand all the different ways that
the string could look yeah and if you go
through that very complicated
mathematics which the three of us did
different pieces of during that period
And Out pops the electron the quark and
even the graviton the force of gravity
that's the that was the most interesting
thing um and just say the graviton is
how does it relate to gravity the
graviton is to gravity what the photon
is to uh electromagnetism it is the
particle that carries the gravitational
force and David can speak to this better
but the consistency of string theory
demands that you have gravity it's you
don't get it's not like Quantum field
Theory you can't add or subtract it's an
all or nothing
proposition and since it was an All or
Nothing proposition it better have
everything we see yeah and and it does
and in the earlier days of string theory
when they weren't using it for a unified
theory it was annoying that there was
this graviton when they were trying to
scatter protons which doesn't appear and
um and then people said hey maybe this
doesn't solve the strong interactions
but solves everything else yeah so so as
you're saying historically these ideas
first were developed to understand some
of the things that you made an enormous
mark on trying to understand the strong
nuclear force so String Theory really uh
emerg actually string theory is is now
what is it um 55 years old really
started around 1968 in an attempt to
understand the strong nuclear force
which binds We Now understand quarks and
antiquarks together with a a color
chromodynamic field which is kind of a
generalization of electricity and
magnetism and string
theory We Now understand that if you
take a quark and antiquark pull it apart
the flux the flux lines the force lines
of
chromodynamics get squeezed into a tube
and so the mezon Quark antiquark pair
the kind of particles we produce in
these accelerators behave a lot like fat
strings so particles is one way of
describing what's going on and very good
at Short distances where we see quirks
moving around but at long distances a
better description which by the way we
haven't yet completely found is these
flux tubes we say or fat strings that
led to string theory String Theory came
from experiment but not experiment on
gravity yes or a unified version of but
rather strong nuclear
particles
so again those we'll perhaps shortly get
to we talk about particles we talk about
strings but sometimes they're really the
same thing yeah we will definitely get
to that there different ways of looking
at the same physics and that
understanding has greatly improved in
attempts to then push that
farther consistently mathematically
construct a rigorous theory of these
extended objects it turned out that one
of the extended objects a closed string
not one a tube but a closed string had
all the properties of gravity gravitons
the Quant of gravity that set the theory
back actually in the beginning because
that's not what they wanted they wanted
a theory of the nuclear force there's no
gravity but later and that was really
green and uh Schwarz Schwarz and um
veneziano
susin well not in framework
Joel Shero unfortunately died young who
realized that okay maybe not a theory of
we have a better theory of nuclear force
but could be a unified theory of gravity
and the other forces and as Andy Andy
noted when you look at you know the list
of properties of the different ways the
string can vibrate within there you see
things that at least look like they
could be an electron or a quark or
the particles called gluons of the
strong nuclear force or particles like w
and z boson of the weak nuclear force so
everything seems to be coming together
and unified under this picture there is
one quality of of string theory that is
probably worth emphasizing now here too
which is we live in a world that has
apparently three dimensions of space and
one of time but when when looked at the
mathematics of this string approach that
seemed not to jive with what the
mathematics required so I just wanted
you know the idea of higher Dimensions
is something that sounds deeply
mysterious but I was going to just take
30 seconds to explain the basic idea and
then we can go forward what it even
means to have higher Dimensions so if we
could just bring up that little graphic
that has a point particles there's a
zero dimensional object no length no
width no height of course you can see it
so it does have a little bit just for
visual purposes but if we now copy this
part particle over and so that we have
two of these guys and we join them
together we find a one-dimensional
object align and if we now copy over
this line so that we have two of these
lines if we connect up all the vertices
we now have a two-dimensional object a
square we play the same game to go to
higher Dimensions make a copy of the
square connect up all of the
corresponding vertices of course we get
a cube three dimensions but now we can
go further copy the cube connect all the
corresponding vertices and now we have
this beautiful example of a higher
dimensional shape a hyper Cube Tesseract
and so when you look at this guy here we
are projecting down to a two-dimensional
screen that we three-dimensional beings
can see but the idea is to go from zero
to one to two to three to four and
onward it's not all that mysterious so
we have this you know beautiful way of
thinking about higher dimension ions but
but Edward this is mathematics and when
we studied String Theory where were we
LED in terms of the structure of
SpaceTime so String Theory at least in
its simplest form requires 10 Dimensions
six extra ones to make sense out of it
we usually assume that the six extra
dimensions are very tiny so we don't see
them in everyday life in fact because of
quantum uncertainty the particles and
fields are completely spread over The
Six Dimensions in fact we can show a
little little picture of what what that
would look like so you know this would
be a schematic representation of those
extra Dimensions curled up and if you
were examining the microscopic structure
of space in some sense vaguely it would
look like this according to string
theory I think the first to explain that
you could have tiny extra Dimensions
that you wouldn't see in ordinary life
were probably Einstein and Bergman in
about
1937 regardless though in the context of
string theory the the extra dimensions
are put to good use in the following
sense probably everyone here is familiar
with electrons but if you're not a
physicist you probably don't know that
there are two cousins of the electron
the muon and the tal there's an amazing
duplication of particles that we don't
understand very well and extra
Dimensions with a lot of more room for
the strings to vibrate are part of
technically what goes into the fact that
string theory can naturally generate all
those particles of the standard model
and so going even a little further on
that I idea those extra dimensions are
made really small in part because we
can't see them they better be pretty
small but the strings are pretty small
too and as you're saying they can
vibrate into those extra dimensions and
that additional room freedom for
vibration gives rise to a longer list of
properties of those vibrations which can
include more exotic particles like you
say like the the muon or the toao or the
other generations of particles yes David
these uh
so you know the standard model we have
of particle physics which electron
neutrinos quarks or different copies of
the same structure leave all of these
many of these properties of these basic
constituents unanswered and and perhaps
even unanswerable within that framework
because you could change it in principle
according they change it and they're
bizarre yeah String Theory really that
those first attemp s at compactification
and producing a using the extra
Dimension to produce a specific unified
theories was truly remarkable because it
gave totally new ways of explaining the
multiplicity of of quirks the values for
their masses the strange hierarchy of
masses the so on and so on I you know
and it realizes by the way a centuries
old
gold uh of Plato to
reduce physics to Geometry these
properties were really not
understandable in simple modifications
of the standard model Quantum field
Theory but in string theory they sort of
had geometrical explanations extremely
beautiful and appealing
unfortunately but before we get to
unfortunately let's let's Revel in where
we've gotten so if we can just do like a
little summary of of we're sort of I
don't know by 1990s or so we are with
string theory so if you can just rattle
off some of the things that summarize so
String Theory combines general
relativity and quantum mechanics huge
achievement number two string theory
unifies all forces and all matter at
least has the capacity to have potential
potential yes exactly so I'm being
careful with my language here and you're
staying on me which is great and finally
it offers is IR rationale for
fundamental physics what you were just
saying David without this approach you
could put any Fields into a Quantum
field Theory any particles and some
within reason any properties but in
string theory you don't have that
flexibility so so certainly like as I
entered the field you know later on you
know in 19 mid1 1980s this is enormously
exciting and so I mean Andy as of 1990
what was your perspective on on where we
were were you starting to think like
Lord Kelvin like this may be because
some were saying things like that at the
time um I think I'm afraid I was a
prematurely
cynical as as you can see it I roted
some of my so I it you know there is
this very hard uh problem which is it is
fantastically hard um to measure the
gravitational Corrections there's motion
yeah Quantum Corrections there's motion
gravitational Corrections the hydrogen
atom and now we could also say we will
never be able to make an accelerator big
enough that could see a
string
and I didn't think we were going
to uh uh go on and show that do do
experiments and verify or by 1990 yeah I
didn't think we were going to go on and
sort of verify it in the same way that
we verified the the strong and the week
interactions however I think I am well
known as one of the most enthusiastic
people about string theory and I I don't
think that that is the axis that we want
to judge it on and we will get to those
other yeah things do you mind if we
judge it on that axis first and just get
it out of the way you so let me just say
this it I think it is the gets an
A++ for
being completely consistent with the
universe as we know it it's the only
theory that we have that could in
principle describe the universe that we
live in with all its idiosyncratic
features and that is not a mean feat but
as far as being a a a theory that we
could measure and verify in some
concrete ways it's not logically
precluded but I think it's going to be
very hard and would require some luck
and people are working hard on doing it
and they should be and I'm I'm not
criticizing them for doing it I'm and
I'm I'm glad they're doing it but I I
don't have great hope for it right now I
don't have great hope for yeah so let's
just turn to then a series of questions
one of which indeed will be the one that
you were just uh speaking to in terms of
just to get sort of a feel of the
challenges and the achievements of of
string theory so question number one is
can we test the theory can String Theory
be tested experimentally now you quickly
made reference to the fact that seeing a
string directly I mean that would be a
pretty good test right you look down you
see it but just to give people a feel at
least in the conventional formulation a
string is to an atom as a tree is to the
entire observable universe so that's how
small strings are on even Atomic scales
and you're right seeing them directly is
going to be pretty tough but people have
certainly put forward other ways of
testing them and and I'd like to get
your feel for this because String Theory
like the the more full name that we
often use a super string theory and
we're not going to do a whole discussion
of super symmetry which is the super and
super String Theory but many people
thought that that would be the key to at
least finding circumstantial evidence or
at least some thought it and and so if
we could just bring up just what the
particles of a super symmetric Theory
would be like it's basically for every
known particle there's a partner
particle according to this deep symmetry
in the theory for the electron selectron
for the quarks squarks and so forth who
of you would have been betting on this
being our first clue finding those
particles David well number one string
the
does not require or imply low energy or
easily observable superm yes my for me
the clues for super symmetry were more
that it answered other questions which
had to do with the structure of the
standard model icept the Hig sector
which is unnatural in some ways uh dark
matter which has been observed and we
don't know what it is and super symmetry
offered a nice clue as to how that um
you know why that the Dark Matter
content of the universe would be what we
have meas what astronomers have measured
it to be these Clues still remain by the
way yes uh and uh and so syry still by
the way does remain as a viable
candidate just large some
portion not
99% of the potential phase for
discovering haven't been found
so okay we've learned a lot from the
non-discovery of super Symmetry and we
continue to look for it as we continue
to look for the uh origin of dark matter
as we continue to try to understand the
strange higs sector and so on and so on
so but you know there are there have
been a lot of interesting ideas about
how one might directly experimentally uh
observe String Theory or test String
Theory they just
haven't so far worked for example cosmic
strings yes you could have strings produ
the universe inflates dramatically in
its early history we believe and that
can pull these very small strings out to
be the size of the universe or the
Galaxy and then you they
would actually function as gravitational
lens the low low energy density is so
high within the string that they would
bend around it we would see multiple
images but very different than multiple
images from a point
lens so people have looked for that
continue to look for it doesn't seem to
be there such cosmic strings don't seem
to be there in abundance but that would
be a way so it it is incorrect to say I
think that string there is not testable
yeah if it's not testable it's not
physics it is testable it's just
difficult yeah it's difficult perhaps
partly because we're at so we're so
small or so big but also because perhaps
we haven't thought of the right tests
there are other tests that uh well
Edward you you put forward some tests
like fractionally charge particles of a
particular strange I mean and and and
you know where do you think we are at
least in the journey that should one day
perhaps I I'm sympathetic to what Andie
said which is that we need some good
fortune so yes could discover
fractionally charged particles created
in the Big Bang in cosmic rays it's not
out of the question you'd have to say
we'd have to be rather lucky to discuss
that discover that given all that we
know yes right so Andy any any any
further thoughts on how we should
interpret our current state of lack of
evidence for super symmetry lack of
evidence for gravitational lensing by
linear defects lack of finding of these
exotically fractionally charged
particles is is just en root to one day
having some evidence or too early to
even ask a question like that we don't
have a map Brian if you got a map give
it to me yeah you know um you know we we
we uh we have some really interesting
facts about mathematical physics we have
lots of data of experimental data about
the real world of different kinds of
course accelerator data doesn't seem to
be coming in faster and faster but
there's lots of astronomical data that
it's just pouring in and we have you
know we we just need to all keep working
on whatever we find interesting yeah
because there isn't we don't know what
the path is yeah yeah David but by the
way I I
uh at this point with our understanding
that I think you're going to come to
especially
the our understanding of dualities
between string theory and Quantum field
Theory uh they fit together so well that
you could say and I believe this to be
true that they're part of the same
framework which contains String Theory
Quantum field Theory and Quantum field
theory is extremely well tested and
we're continually learning about
properties of string the of sorry of
quantum field Theory which some of them
actually Bear on string theory maybe the
string theory of mesons but that's you
know uh continuously connected in to
fundamental String Theory to gravity so
it it's really
hard one can argue that we can use the
real world which is in our Theory so
successful precise you're the real world
to make a a connection to experiment now
it's an incredibly important point and
one will come to toward the very end
that the most recent work ties together
strength Theory and Quantum field theory
in a profoundly interesting important
way so in some sense we're not talking
about something so radically different
it's just a different formulation but
let's just move on to a couple of other
questions because um next question is
does string theory describe a unique
Universe because one of the nice things
Edward that you mentioning was the way
these extra dimensions are curled up has
an impact on the way that the strings
can vibrate which has an impact on the
kinds of particle properties that those
strings will appear to have when I was a
beginning student I got very excited
about the extra Dimensions because I
like geometry and Mathematics and
there's this beautiful complex geometry
richy flat surface and so forth and it
seemed like there were very few ways
that you could curl up the extra
dimensions and that was very exciting
because it seemed to suggest very few
universes that changed over time as as
people found more and more ways in which
you could curl up these extra Dimensions
from you know five in in in like the
first paper that you wrote I think you
listed maybe like five possible examples
or three or something like that and that
grew to like a 100 examples a thousand
examples a gazillion 10 to the 500 you
know it just exploded over time so what
what's your view on on thinking about
string theory and the goal of having a
unique universe come out of a
theory U it's certainly true now that
the theory appears to be unique yes but
we don't see that the solution of the
equations that we give rise to our
universe is unique and I have to tell
you that observational discoveries are
not very encouraging for the uniqueness
either both the acceleration of the
cosmic expansion and the failure
uh the fact that we explored the
energies of the electro week theory of
the higs particle without seeing what
would account for that energy scale both
of
these raise serious questions about
whether we actually do live in a world
that is unique in the sense that
Einstein envis envisaged so and when you
say that you imagine if you go like
sufficiently far out Beyond The Cosmic
Horizon things in principle could have
different properties well it's a
question yeah the acceleration of the
expansion does not suggest to me that
we're living in a world with the kind of
uniqueness
that I imagine for it let's say in the
period in the 80s that you talked about
earlier right so we may just have to
potentially live with this idea that it
may have been asking too much it would
be nice if that's
wrong but we might have to the world the
world was not created for our
convenience and understanding it
yes uh absolutely the case all right so
so another question Andy you know we
discussed how black holes and the Big
Bang are a natural Arena where gravity
and quantum mechanics need to come
together to understand what's going on
and and you and kin vafa uh have you
know done you know pivotal work in
understanding black holes um it's a
complex subject but you can just give us
a bit of a sketch of how string theory
has resolved certain black hole
paradoxes that you know articulated you
know even you know with Stephen Hawking
way back in the
1970s yeah so uh Stephen Hawking and and
also beckenstein yes of course um they
gave us a a famous formula it's the
thing that talking is most famous for
you can write that formula in many
different ways but one way to write it
is that it it's a formula that tells you
uh how many gigabytes of of information
you can store inside a black hole and it
turns out to be proportional to the
area and they derived this in a
breathtakingly or aing derived this in a
breathtakingly elegant and simple manner
in fact we're showing a little bit of a
visual right here if that's sort of a
black hole the the bits if you will are
stored on the Avent the surface of the
black hole yeah it was a very simple
argument
but it didn't
explain what uh the bits were made
of so it it's it's as if you took your
smartphone and you wanted to know what
its storage capacity is and you just put
photos in there and
um and at some point you couldn't put
any more in and then you know how many
bits it has so so he inferred how many
bits there are in a black hole and the
really it was such a simple argument he
didn't need to know String Theory alls
he need to know all he really needed to
assume that somehow or other quantum
mechanics and general relativity are
consistently reconciled and we believe
that just because they're here and
they're they're part of our universe
yeah so if you have a theory which is
supposed to FL explain the inner
workings of quantum mechanics and
general
relativity it should be able to actually
tear the smartphone open and count those
bits and see that it agrees with what
with what Hawking does and so uh when we
first started working on string theory
this problem was already on the table
but string theory was pretty
complicated and we didn't we didn't have
the tools to do the computation but then
by the we kept understanding it better
and better and better and better and by
the mid90s it was clear that we
understood the theory well enough so
that we could tear the black hole
smartphone apart and see see what kind
of bits were sitting in
there and this was really a moment of
truth because if we counted the
bits and they had come out to be the
wrong number yeah String Theory would
then be
inconsistent and uh on the other hand if
we got the right number um then uh we
would know that uh String Theory
understood a lot about the the Deep way
that quantum mechanics and general
relativity is put together and of course
we did get the right number and we got
the right number in in every with lots
of parameters in it with in every
situation that we could compute and it
also was one of the main times that
string theory solved a problem that
somebody else posed you know if you have
a new assumption about physics you
shouldn't just make your own problems
and solve them using it you you want to
solve a problem that somebody else has
been worrying about this case it had
been a quarter of a century that they
had been trying to understand this and
and and string theory gave the answer so
so that's one of the feelings that
despite the fact that we aren't going to
measure it I feel we're on on to
something here and we should keep keep
keep going to see where it leads so
that's a very sensitive test and a kind
of detailed mathematical test of the of
the consistency of string theory both
internally but also with things that had
emerged from non-ring theoretic
considerations as you say Hawking wasn't
working with string theory was just
having a kind of loose marriage between
general relativity and Quantum has loose
enough to be able to do those
calculations but not a full Theory but
yet the agreement is is is remarkable so
Edward when when these results came
forward and of course You've Been
instrumental in in pushing our
understanding in so many different
directions but was this a moment for you
where it really felt like this is one
more piece of evidence that things are
really working it was very dramatic um
so I think the calculation was done in
1996 that was a period where there was a
lot of Rapid progress in particular Joe
Pinsky had
discovered a new building block and
string theory that we hadn't understood
the D brains and that made possible the
calculation that Andy and krun did and
somehow it was clear that at least in
that example we then understood the
fundamental building BLX well enough
that we could count the quantum States
of aacle which it would not have been
possible prior to 1995 yeah and David so
where where did this all leave you I
mean obviously you you invented one of
the key string theories itself and here
enormously exciting and uh but of course
it left open many other questions about
black holes and the remarkable thing is
that many of those have been answered
very recently yeah so the black holes
posed many fascinating paradox apparent
paradoxes between general relativity and
Quantum mechanic the loss of information
problem you know you throw stuff into a
black
hole can't see it Hain says told us
black holes radiate eventually disappear
where does the information go how does
it get
out uh you know I remember um a time
where when Hawking actually it's about
50 years ago Hawking posed this problem
and it led to a a really serious debate
between sort of the particle theory
people and the general
relativists Quantum people class and
general Rel
uh because Hawking really was saying
quantum mechanics has to be modified
quantum mechanics is wrong in a sense
information is not
preserved and the people Quantum field
theorist Bion lard said no way and this
went on for quite a while and I'm not
sure everyone agrees that it has been
resolved in our favor Hawking eventually
agreed and but the recent advances in
understanding where the information is
stored within black holes and how it
eventually is recovered
outside um has been amazing yeah and uh
I think the problem is clearly resolved
right with the Triumph of yeah of quom
mechanics totally agree I would argue
sbert I want to just turn to one other
question which is not directly in the
realm say of physics but has String
Theory inspired breakthroughs in
mathematics this is an arena where
there's been so much can you give us a
sense of of of why string theory has had
the impact it has I'd say string theory
has had a lot of impact in mathematics
what so as Quantum field theory yes
since the development of the standard
model once the standard model was in
place which was by the mid '70s
physicists started needing mathematical
tools that were unfamiliar and in turn
it turned out that um physicists were
sometimes inspired by Quantum field
Theory and later by String Theory uh
able to make predictions about
mathematics that came as surprises to
the
mathematicians in some sense Quantum
field Theory and string theory have deep
truths but they're very difficult
subjects
mathematically
and the people who work on them tend to
be physicists therefore and as long as
that's the situation I think physicists
will be able to continue to surprise the
mathematicians with some of those
insights yeah um and and you know one of
the other key reasons within the string
theory context is we've needed to bring
in so much mathematical architecture in
order to understand these higher
dimensional spaces and the surfaces that
strings sweep out as they move so
there's so much opportunity for a cross
talk between the two that you know even
if String Theory were to go away let's
say your calculation of black hole
entropy had not agree with Hawkings the
mathematical contributions of string
theory would would stand because they
are Beyond any particular test
thankfully though it all seems to be
working out but I do want to turn now to
in our sort of final subject what what
many consider the most uh important
collection of recent advances that will
take us right up to the moment and they
all go under the heading of what's known
as
Duality and you know just want to give
people a feel for what we mean by
Duality so I'm going to start with just
a couple of very very simple examples
just to give a feel for it so you know
know if you consider a concept expressed
in two different languages the dog jumps
now I can't pronounce on the right but
you probably can Andy since you know I
think you are relatively fluent in
Chinese but I'll I'll I won't put you on
the spot but here we have one concept
the dog jumps in two in two different
languages they're dual to each other
they are expressing one in the same
abstract concept but obviously in very
different ways another example of
Duality is uh Arabic numerals versus
Roman numerals three expressed in two
different ways or the number 16 in two
different ways and I like this example
in particular because when it comes to
the dog jumps whether you express it in
English or Chinese you're basically
communicating the same information in
more or less the same parallel way but
with Arabic numerals and Roman numerals
if you ever try to do a
calculation with Roman
numerals it's pretty tough to do that
calculation on the right hand side but
it's pretty easy to do it on the left
hand side so the point
is when you have dual descriptions of
the same idea sometimes there is a great
benefit in using one approach versus the
other because one approach can give you
more insight into certain things than
the other and this is what we have found
in string theory in Spades and so we'll
get to the sort of the the the most
influ fluential of recent times it's
called ads CFT Duality it's a complex
name for something simple don't let's
not go to there yet but Ed I first want
to just start yes is it wrong is there
something that Roman numerals are better
for that's an interesting question I I
don't I for for confusing six-year-olds
maybe that's uh that's that's one
because usually usually in a duality one
side is good for one thing the other
Duality is good for something else yes I
agree yeah that's really what I was
going to say as well in our dualities
neither is better than the other they
each are are better for their own
purposes for own purposes yes right so
we'll have to come up with a purpose for
Roman numerals but I I can't do it I
cannot do it on the spot um they look
good they look really good yeah I mean
come on yeah exactly thank you Andy um
so so Edward you know you you
articulated um a whole collection of
dualities which really helped us with
not really a problem but an irritating
quality of string theory
that as it was developed there were many
different versions of string theory so
so David Gross and collaborators develop
what technically is called the heterotic
string and you know we the type one
string and the type two they're all
based on vibrating strings but they they
looked different in detail and then you
found that those differences were kind
of like the difference between Arabic
numerals and Roman roughly speaking so
just tell us what you found well I found
pieces of that many colleagues had found
other pieces um as it was developed by
the mid 80s there were five different
consistent versions of string theory
which differed by properties like
whether the strings are Loops or could
also be open strings with ends and
whether they were electrical insulators
or electrical
superconductors and of course there was
a mystery if one of those five theories
describes our world who lives in the
other four universes it turned out
though as we understood by the '90s that
the five different string theories are
different limiting cases of the same
unified theory which is the candidate
for super unification under different
physical conditions one or another gives
a better description a more economical
description and easier to calculate but
they are all different limiting cases of
the same Theory and so all of a sudden
Not only was String Theory a unified
theory gravity and quantum mechanics
capable of unifying all other forces but
now the different string theories were
unified into sort of a mega unification
which was a very powerful kind of
Duality and there were many other
dualities that we just don't have time
to describe a number of us were involved
in dualities to do with the shapes of
the extra extra dimensions in strength
Theory and so forth but I want to turn
to the adfc of Duality that David Yi
made reference to this is an
intimidating name anti- Deiter space
conformal field Theory duality
you don't have to memorize the name what
I'd like to do is just try to give
people a a feel for this I have some
visuals in a moment that will attempt to
do so but David can you just give us the
broad brush perspective on on what it is
and and and what it tells
us well we had to do
listening so to the universe is kind of
big it's helps to would be nice to put
it in a box which is difficult to do in
in quantum gravity or gravity in general
because the walls of the Box are have
mass and they pull but there's a turns
out a a kind of Einstein in space
solution of Einstein's equations with a
cosmological
constant the opposite sign of what we
observe curves the universe in the
opposite way and creates a
box that's very very useful it turns out
I'm not discussing how this you know
arose but what it consists of and a box
means that there's a there's a boundary
at the
box and you could ask you know what is
the physics on the boundary and it turns
out that in string theory in a space
where five of the dimensions are a kind
of
box and five the other five dimensions
are C up into a
sphere uh the box is has a very simple
description the Dynamics on the box very
simple description in terms of ordinary
Quantum field Theory with rigid geometry
so there the space time is fixed and
looks very much like that geometry in
this
room
and no dynamical gravity no general
relativity if you want no need to do
quantum gravity just ordinary Quantum
field Theory and starting with these
strings in 10 Dimensions the physics on
the boundary is that of a close very
beautiful elegant relative of the
standard model yeah the same kind of
physic so this is not totally
coincidental based on what we previously
understood at all but the precise
mathematical equivalence of these two
descriptions is of enormous value to us
which is why it's
dominated speculative research in this
field for the last 25 years
completely because it allows us to
explore String Theory using
wellestablished experimentally verified
if you want tools of quantum field
Theory to learn about black holes
quantum gravity string theory and vice
versa in the regimes of string theory
which after all is a generalization of
Einstein's equations in case is where we
can solve Einstein's equations and use
them we can learn
about problems or issues in Quantum
field Theory which are extremely
difficult uh so it goes both ways yeah
but most importantly it ties a theory of
just a quantum mechanical Theory with
rigid geometry before Einstein to
quantum
gravity to dynamical space time
and it produces higher Dimensions at
least one Higher Dimension yeah so it is
the basis of a feeling that has existed
in string theory for a long time that
SpaceTime itself might best be viewed as
an emerging Concept in this case from a
or well hardly ordinary very difficult
Quantum field
Theory and uh suggests that
you know with have two dual descriptions
which as Edward said one is good
sometimes one is good in other regimes
they surely emerge from some unified
description which we don't know but if
they do it is extremely unlikely that
SpaceTime the way we understand it will
be inherent in that more fundamental
representation I think much of what
we're making advances and trying to
explore is what is spacetime made out of
what is the how do we understand the
emergence of space and especially of
time so that's a actually a final
question I like to get to in just a few
minutes that was a a beautiful summary
of of ads CFT Duality I we have some
visuals just to underscore exactly what
you just said and just to sort of give
the audience a sense this is the Box in
some sense that you're talking about all
we going to do a three-dimension
latitude longitude and Radial Direction
and if you were to take away the top of
the box so you can sort of see inside
this spherical box as you're saying the
outside in this lower dimensional
version has two Dimensions the inside
which often in the field is called the
bulk this blue area has three dimensions
so there you have a difference of
dimensionality between the outside and
the entirety and then if we keep on
going the idea of the dualities that
I've have strings vibrating in the
inside that's equivalent to point
particles that you can see living on the
outside so a particular kind of quantum
field theory on the outside where
there's no gravity being completely
equivalent to a quantum gravity Theory
because it has strings that are
vibrating within the inside so if we can
summarize what we're finding in with
this exactly what you just said David
you have a a rigid geometry on the
outside you got a flexible geometry on
the inside and yet these two theories
are meant to be as dual as you know
three and you know 111 in Roman numerals
right and so if we can go just to the
the summary slide of all what we find
here we have on the far left we have
this idea that a theory that lives in a
lower Dimension the yellow is equivalent
to a theory that lives in higher
Dimensions this Blue Area showing that
dimensionality is somehow some emerging
property not fundamental if we go on to
the next one a theory of Point particles
field theory on the outside equivalent
to strings in the inside that's your
point that field Theory and string
theory are part of the same overarching
rubric and finally just to reiterate
that last point a theory that has
quantum gravity on the inside being
equivalent to Theory with no gravity
rigidity on the outside and of course we
should mention Juan malesa was the one
of the key people where this idea
culminated and of course everybody on
this stage has made important
contributions to this Duality and the
implications that it has so I just want
to spend the rest of our time
Andy what do you make of of this
particular Duality how does it change
your thinking say on on the nature of
SpaceTime the very Arena of reality
first of all
it's incredible the amount of I mean
you've made some pictures here which
don't capture the
incredible amount of structure that is
involved the self-consistency of having
a theory on the boundary yeah that uh
was uh equivalent to the theory in in
the um interior and I guess I'll I'll
say some words which you haven't uh said
so far the so-called holographic
principle yes please yes so the
holographic principle is um precisely
that um theories of quantum gravity
which we we really still don't
understand in in general and we don't
know how far we are from from fully
understanding all of the quantum
theories of gravity including the ones
that might describe the real world
including many things about String
Theory there's still a lot we we we
don't understand but uh I think of the
idea as originating in the work of of of
beckenstein in Hawking and in that
picture you drew you drew a similar
picture where you had bits on the
outside you had bits on the outside and
um and that had nothing to do with
string theory yes and so
uh and and indeed the thing that vafa
and I did was the first examp was one of
the first examples of a there were other
ones the for an early example of some
sort of holographic uh duality of this
type and it works so well and reconciles
so many puzzles one hopes that or it's
interesting to um investigate the
possibility that it is completely
General so the context in which we
understand it very well are the ones
that come out of symmetry in which you
out of string the in which you have a a
universe with with negative curvature
and I think there is the hope there and
this is an important program in in in
our our field now to that there should
be some way to generalize this beautiful
relationship to universes like the ones
we inhabit which are nearly flat or even
in a better um approximation are
expanding to the infinite future so that
is a very exciting problem to think
about we clearly don't understand
everything about it yet uh but we
understand an amazing amount in some
specific cases yeah so so Edward I'm
interested in your thoughts on on how
your views of SpaceTime have evolved as
discoveries in in in physics and
strength Theory over the past few
decades and in particular one of the
really interesting results of of this
kind of physics has been to relate you
know quantum entanglement the
connections between different parts of
the outside the the boundary the yellow
region that that in some sense is
encoding the way SpaceTime in the
interior is sort of knitted
together where does this leave you
thinking that what the nature of
SpaceTime is well to be more
conservative I would just say that we've
suspected that the difficulties with
understand understanding quantum gravity
have suggested for a long time that the
SpaceTime Continuum as Onin envisaged it
might not really exist at very short
distances and ads CFT has given us an
inspiring example that we actually
understand where SpaceTime and emerges
from something else unfortunately we
haven't been able to generalize the
lesson in whatever way it should be
generalized to apply to the real world
as and was telling us a moment ago so
different discoveries over the time but
maybe ads CFT was the most tramatic have
given us a much more concrete
understanding that in some sense
SpaceTime should the emergence but we do
not have a systematic picture and can
you give us a feel David or Edward or
Andy when when we say SpaceTime is
emergent what what would that mean like
starting with a theory that doesn't have
space and time to begin with and then
space and time somehow arise from the
Dynamics of the theory I mean DAV we
don't know but obviously but uh we have
this example yeah
there the in some versions you can say
that all of space emerges we have
formulations of string theory and then
Dimensions with which um are based on a
pure quantum mechanical Theory with no
space so they're no they're just degrees
of
oscillators that's quite
remarkable so given that example it is
very reasonable to expect the hope that
expect or hope or a combination that
this is general that all theories which
are based on some kind of
space have formulations which or at
least dynamical space yeah time however
is somewhat different time is always the
most mysterious of all of our
Concepts and none of these examples
truly have emergent time and it is
extremely difficult for a physics or
physic to imagine formulation of physics
which doesn't have time in it from the
beginning because the whole point of
physics is to make
predictions given what we know now to
predict but if there's no
and among the many open questions that
Edward said we need to do generalize
this emerging space to other situations
we definitely need to understand what
time which Einstein brought together
with space in both special and general
relativity in what sense could that
conceivably be an emerging
concept has time in it the place where
this hits up on one of the other
fundamental problems that faces physics
for the first
time time again uh is the beginning of
the universe yeah we are forced by our
understanding of cosmology extrapolating
back to consider the earliest possible
moments in the universe but what does
that mean and what does it mean to have
a theory of the initial conditions of
the universe how did it begin is it
unique these are questions physics has
never been forced which try ignored
it never been forced to address but now
we are we have no example of anal
examples of successful theories of the
origin in in science not religion but
so I think these are all connected and
are at the core of the most difficult
conceptual problems that we have been
forced to consider and 40 years ago we
were happy to ignore those all we wanted
was a theory that explained the
properties of the standard model we
couldn't calculate right so we only have
a a few minutes left and I just wanted
to just come to
some final
articulation however you define that for
where we are in the state of strength
the and look all of us are our
professors we all have that awful task
of grading
students although Edward maybe you never
need to grade students you know you
you've avoided that time
once um but however you want to Define
it imagine a student called string comes
to your office and you know string has
done some pretty cool things put
together gravity and quantum
mechanics uh been able to unify matter
and the forces in one rubric of
vibrating strings this interesting idea
of extra Dimensions comes in and even
that can be leveraged to yield other
vibrations that can account for the the
generation the family structure the
particles as Edward is talking about
this thing called string has given
insight to black holes allow us to
understand the entropy of black holes
but you know on experimental front
String's not done so well as yet you
know in terms of uniqueness of a unit
well so so when you take all that
together David if you don't mind what
how would you assess the state of string
theory
B+
[Laughter]
B+ nice and
concise Edward how however you want to
answer that it doesn't have to be a
grade it could be whatever you you
describe it well I I think a letter
grade won't do justice to the
situation uh I think there are a lot of
reasons to think that string theory is
on the right track and I think what has
been accomplished in theoretical physics
in the last 40 years is much more than
would have been if we hadn't had the
good luck to stumble upon String Theory
as a way of getting beyond the framework
we know but as for how far we are in the
direction of wherever it is we're trying
to get there's no way to know and as you
know life does not unfortunately come
with
guarantees Andy the last
word okay well first of all I I want to
emphasize that strength theory is not
what we were doing in 1984 right string
theory has
now uh come to be a word that is used
for everybody who is working on anything
that is going beyond the standard laws
of physics I'm myself trying to push
Beyond the Edge of what we know I have
not uh I'm regularly referred to as a
string theist though I myself have not
written a paper of my my 80 papers in
the last 10 years two of them are string
theory proper are string theory proper
yeah so it really is everything
everything that we're we're trying to do
but I think and and almost all of that
is inspired by taking lessons from what
we have learned from from String Theory
proper but I myself um and everybody
looks at the different axes which you
might evaluate the
subject everybody should everybody
should make up their own mind but I
giving it an
A+ otherwise I wouldn't be working on
it and and and I I
think I think I am very excited about
what we are going we have there has not
been a moment since I was a graduate
student in which okay except for the one
year I spent on Stringfield field Theory
and the two things on hard derivative
gravity let's forget those but but but
but um there has not barely been a
moment when I wasn't involved when
people around me weren't involved in
something that seemed like really was
pushing forward the the edges of
knowledge in some important way and that
is more true now than ever I think thank
you so so for I give I'm giving it A+
yep and say that you know my most
exciting times I mean David we never
really had an opportunity to work
together but the time I spent at The
Institute for advaned study edra when we
were working on topology change in
different ways most exciting times in my
life when you and I were working on
black holes turning into Elementary
particles and topology change as well
the most exciting thing so thank you so
much for the way that you all have
enriched my life and please join me in
thanking all of these gentlemen for this
conversation
[Music]